depuis samedi ils se relaient sur ce
rond point et c'est gilet jaune seront
encore là demain
ici personne ne comptent aller
manifester à paris on va pas s'amuser à
dépasser notre pognon qu'on a peur pour
aller à paris 2 trains tout ça c'est
trop cher donc on préfère aller continue
notre action ici au niveau des péages on
verra on verra ce qu'on fera au fur et à
mesure entre on va tous les soirs ce
qu'on fait le lendemain sur cet autre
point de rassemblement les gilet jaune
se prépare déjà à passer une nouvelle
journée sur place
pas question de lever ce barrage
filtrant on va le maintenir il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
bon voilà on fait ce qu'on peut il ya
déjà assez de monde qui va à paris alors
ils vont rester et prévoit déjà d' être
plus nombreux demain devant ce péage de
l'a 31 le groupe de gilet jaune compte
aussi sur davantage de mobilisation ce
samedi où continuent après il ya des
barrages partout surtout les péages de
dijon déjà
donc nous on va tout bloquer sur dijon
d'aller bloquer à bloquer c'est un grand
mot à faire du barrage filtrant quoi que
du barrage filtrant et puis on sent les
gens ne payerons pas le péage et puis
ils sont contents des opérations péages
gratuits ou d'autres
après ça commence à nous nous embêter un
peu on va vraiment bloqué a apprécié
veulent pas comprendre qu'on commence à
en avoir marre de tout on va durcir un
peu le ton va dire et puis voilà ça va
se faire pour se faire entendre les
gilet jaune de côte-d'or promettent
d'amplifier leurs actions sur le terrain
demain sans en dire plus
[Musique]